2026년 5월 6일 수요일 미국 증시 유약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 상승 마감했습니다.
미국과 이란의 분쟁이 흔날 조짐을 보이면서 주요지수는 사상 최고치로 치솟았고 미국과는 하락했습니다.
미국과 이란이 분쟁 해결을 위한 합의에 근접했다는 소식이 시장에 낙관론을 이끌었습니다.
엑시오스는 복수의 소식통을 인용해 미국이 호르무제협의 점진적 재개방과 항구봉쇄해제를 골자로 한 양해의 거세를 이란 측에 전달했다고 보도했습니다.
이에 대해 이란 외무부 대변인 역시 CNBC와의 인터뷰에서 미국 측의 제안을 검토 중이라고 밝혀 사결 기대감을 높였습니다.
트럼프 대통령도 긍정적인 전망에 힘을 보탰습니다.
트럼프 대통령은 이란은 핵무기를 보유하지 않을 것이며
이란도 이에 동의했다고 밝혔습니다.
이어 매우 긍정적인 대화가 오가고 있어 사결 가능성이 매우 높다며
다음 주 중국 방문 이전에 종전이 이뤄질 가능성까지 시사했습니다.
중국 왕위 외교 보장 또한 이란 측과 회담에서 호르무제협에 조속한 재개방을 촉구하고 나섰습니다.
지정학적 긴장 완화와 더불어 견주한 경제지표 및 개업 실적도 증시 상승을 뒷받침했습니다.
금요일 고용보고서 발표를 앞두고 공개된 4월 매우 민간 고용은 1년여 만에 가장 큰 폭으로 증가한 것으로 집계됐습니다.
이에 따라 SNP 외지수는 1.5% 상승했습니다.
특히 AMD가 18% 급등하며 반도체 주 랠리를 주도했고 디즈니 역시 호 실적을 바탕으로 7.5% 오르며 지수 상승을 견인했습니다.
페퍼스톤의 마이클 브라운은
현재 우리는 긴장을 완화하고 지지율을 높여야 합니다.
그 과정이 결코 순탄치는 않겠지만 올바른 궤도를 유지하며 낙관적인 방향으로 흘러간다면 위험자산 투자 심리는 계속해서 탄력을 받을 것이다.
나타시스 어드바이저의 잭 야나시비에이치는
이번 증시의 랠리의 핵심은 AI 투자 열기가 여전히 강하게 살아 있다는 점이다.
EPS와 순이익률 전망이 개선되고 있다는 점이 AI 관련주 상승을 뒷받침하고 있습니다.
2020.5.7.9. 주요 일정 살펴보겠습니다.
경제 지표는 20시 30분 미국 4월 챌린저 감원 계획
21시 30분 미국 1분기 비농업 생산성
22시 30분 미국 1분기 단위 노동 미용
22시 30분 미국 신규 실업상 청구 건수
23시 미국 3월 건설전 around 20%
기상캐스터 배혜지